[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission Ça découvre la
Réunion ensemble ça ne l'est pas alors
allons-nous
comment il est
dans sa même
misérables même alors au 5000 dans la
commune de Saint-Paul plus précisément à
la réserve naturelle nationale de
l'étang Saint-Paul qui nous a découvrir
que ça nous a bien fait au taux de
l'étang allez allons-nous
[Musique]
retrouve mon moment rien que la même mot
qui a des danses derrière Elena la
montagne
[Musique]
et bonjour madame bonjour comment elle
est bien
de repérage pour la prochaine visite
[Musique]
du Grand veinard et voilà tout ce qu'on
voit avec les ravines devant et c'est
grâce à lui en fait que on va avoir de
l'eau dans les temps qui a
amélioréceptif en fait toutes les plus
elles vont dévaler ici et on va pouvoir
avoir un réservoir d'eau qui crée cette
biodiversité incroyable mais du coup là
un raisin naturel c'est quoi ça c'est un
espace protégé par décrées ministériel
donc c'est une zone qu'on a délimitée on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait des
espèces animales et végétales hyper
importante qu'on souhaite protéger et
donc du coup elle devient réserve
naturelle nationale
50 hectares et on rajoute si ravines
grâce à la labellisation Ramsar donc à
cet espace protégé ça fait presque 500
hectares c'est immense et du coup on a
des habitats vraiment très différents
selon où on se situe là on est sur le
sentier de découverte des viviers ou en
fait on va pouvoir d'observer beaucoup
d'espaces végétales très importants pour
nous on parle d'espèces remarquables
patrimoniale comme la massette par
exemple qu'on voit beaucoup là autour de
nous beaucoup d'insectes la libellule
tout le monde connaît et nous on a
beaucoup beaucoup ici avec la demoiselle
en tout cas
une première découverte et nous on va
découvrir la suite regarde ça là on
dirait l'ambiance
monsieur bonjour bonjour
comment il est bien
c'est le club de La Farandole c'est un
club de seniors de Sainte-Clotilde
d'accord
c'est un moment de partage entre nous
parce que bon ben c'est agréable il y a
de pique-nique donc on a prié on a
chanté et maintenant c'est le partage
entre nous il y aura du riz il y aura
des grains
boucané et est-ce que c'est un site où
je trouve les propres et agréables si de
monovini est-ce que tu as dit de moins
bien ça c'est super c'est propre nous on
a découvert ça l'année dernière donc on
est revenu cette année parce que c'est
bien c'est super on peut marcher on peut
bouger on peut se promener sur les
arbres et tout mais en tout cas
les gars allez salut
alors bon Sam il est là ici à la Maison
de la Réserve de l'Étang ben moi si
Miguel est trouvé un petit peu encode la
réserve de détente parce que
Madame bonjour Eddy comment elle était
ça va bien ou même toujours bien
parc Amazon
la réunion nous les larmes mon pays
comment il est la réunion s'amène parle
pas nous aller nous verrez la même un
peu de respect pour mon pays vraiment
d'après depuis son lit au bout de la
terre dans le paradis pour comprendre
la réunion nous les la même mais mon
pays comment il est la réunion sans même
pas nous aller
et ben du coup ça y est nous la pose les
vélos et ben maintenant
alors du coup
Amazon
au niveau de la réserve la location de
vélo à distance électrique et donc les
gens ils peuvent venir soit aussi bien
sûr la demi-journée soit même l'heure ou
soit la journée entière et toi tu peux
en fait utilisent les vélos dans toute
la commune de Saint-Paul alors du coup
ici que ça nous va retrouver alors
exactement ici alors en fait là ici donc
on va retrouver en fait le canal donc un
canal qui va rejeter dans le canal
principal le canal massouci ensuite et
en fait sur ces canal là nous n'aimes
problématique que les liée aux espèces
flottantes que c'est des espèces
envahissantes et là elle peut voir
quelques bouchons derrière nous par
exemple que les causés par ces espèces
là que les considérés comme très
envahissante à la Réunion et comment ça
tu fais pour lutte contre alors en fait
ici on a des moyens du coup que ce soit
manuel ou mécanique manuel en fait c'est
vraiment de
et pour ça rendez vous un prochain
épisode de l'émission de nous cette fois
c'est une phrase dans la commune du
temps à Pont et ne va découvrir le 2
manches en bois derrière la semaine
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]